Shure:  找个
Shure: Find a...
Shure:  稍微大一点的碗
Shure: Slightly bigger bowl.
Shure:  哎这个好
Shure: Ah, this one's good.
Shure:  打两个鸡蛋
Shure: Crack two eggs.
Shure:  然后裹个蛋液
Shure: Then coat it with egg mixture.
Alice:来吧你涮好了没
Alice: Come on, did you rinse it?
Shure:  没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Alice:你会打吗
Alice: Can you crack it?
Shure:  我会啊
Shure: I can.
Shure:  呵这单手打蛋可以啊
Shure: Haha, I can crack eggs with one hand.
Alice:拿入筷子
Alice: Grab some chopsticks.
Alice:你要煎鸡蛋
Alice: Are you going to fry the eggs?
Alice:不要
Alice: No.
Shure:  煎嗯
Shure: Fry, yeah.
Alice:有个蛋壳皮
Alice: There's an eggshell.
Alice:补钙
Alice: Extra calcium.
Alice:你要煎鸡蛋吗
Alice: Are you going to fry the eggs?
Alice:没锅铲好像
Alice: There's no spatula, it seems.
Shure:  没事拿筷子翻一下
Shure: It's fine, just flip it with chopsticks.
Alice:筷子筷子
Alice: Chopsticks, chopsticks.
Alice:再拿个吧
Alice: Grab another one.
Alice:不用他这个
Alice: Don't use that one.
Alice:不刷啊哦
Alice: Not scrubbing it, huh?
Alice:刷过的是吗
Alice: It's already scrubbed, right?
Shure:  刷过的
Shure: Yeah, it's scrubbed.
Shure:  不过好像有点粘
Shure: But it seems a bit sticky.
Alice:竟连个锅铲都没
Alice: There isn't even a spatula.
Alice:艰难呀
Alice: This is tough.
Shure:  这锅太次了
Shure: This pan is really bad.
Alice:还没过场
Alice: Not done yet.
Katrina:  哈哈哈糟了
Katrina: Hahaha, this is a disaster.
Alice: 粘了吗
Alice: Is it sticking?
Katrina:  要不直接洗碗吧
Katrina: How about we just wash the dishes?
Alice:蛋已经
Alice: The egg is already...
Alice:蛋已经糊的没法看了那一面
Alice: The egg is already burnt on one side.
Katrina:  啥呀鸡蛋吗
Katrina: What? The egg?
Alice:糊的要命真服了
Alice: It's burnt to death, I can't believe it.
Shure:  是不油少了
Shure: Maybe there's not enough oil.
Alice:也不少吧
Alice: There's enough, right?
Shure:  对啊这有点吃油感觉
Shure: Yeah, but this pan soaks up oil.
Alice:再放点来得及
Alice: We can add more oil, it's not too late.
Katrina:  然后影响我的心情
Katrina: It's affecting my mood.
Shure:  行了给它捞出来吧
Shure: Alright, let's take it out.
Shure:  这肯定熟了
Shure: It's definitely cooked.
Alice:就这样吧
Alice: Let's leave it at that.
Shure:  对
Shure: Yeah.
Alice:你不撒你不放盐吗
Alice: Aren't you going to add salt?
Alice:你撒盐吗
Alice: Are you adding salt?
Shure:  蘸酱油也行
Shure: Dipping it in soy sauce works too.
Alice:我没酱油
Alice: I don't have soy sauce.
Shure:  我们今天早上补给了
Shure: We restocked this morning.
Katrina:  昨天晚上小蛋糕都吃完了吗
Katrina: Did you finish the little cakes from last night?
Katrina:  嗯昨天晚上小蛋糕都吃完了吗
Katrina: Hmm, did you finish the little cakes from last night?
Alice:嗯没有还有点
Alice: Hmm, there's still a bit left.
Katrina:  放哪放冰箱了吗
Katrina: Where did you put them? In the fridge?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Shure:  煎个蛋都这么费劲
Shure: Even frying an egg is so difficult.
Katrina:  这锅的问题
Katrina: It's the pan's fault.
Alice:现在几点了
Alice: What time is it now?
Katrina:  可以
Katrina: It's fine.
Shure: 晚安
Shure: Goodnight.
Shure:  那边可以了是吗
Shure: Is it good over there?
Alice:焖一会吧
Alice: Let it simmer for a bit.
Alice:我就已经放了很多油了
Alice: I already put a lot of oil in.
Alice:这是炸蛋
Alice: These are fried eggs.
Shure:  管他呢
Shure: Who cares.
Shure:  多来点吧
Shure: Add more.
Shure:  不行
Shure: No way.
Alice:我在这里放的油是我在家里放的两倍
Alice: I used double the oil I normally use at home.
Shure:  我也是我我们家就其实不怎么吃油
Shure: Same here. Actually, we don't use much oil at home.
Shure:  太大了
Shure: It's too much.
Alice:这个锅要是没太多油的话估计要
Alice: If this pan doesn't have enough oil, it might...
Alice:粘成棉花糖
Alice: Stick like cotton candy.
Shure:  信了今天连个好的蛋都煎不出来吗
Shure: Seriously, we can't even make a decent egg today?
Shure:  我不认可
Shure: I don't accept this.
Shure:  炸蛋
Shure: Fried eggs.
Alice:还粘吗不
Alice: Is it still sticking?
Shure:  不沾了
Shure: No, it's not sticking anymore.
Shure:  行应该能成型这回
Shure: Okay, it should hold its shape this time.
Shure:  （歌词）we are the champion my friend
Shure: (Singing) We are the champions, my friend.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Alice:吃一个煎蛋一天的油量已经够了
Alice: Eating one fried egg gives you a day's worth of oil.
Shure:  卧槽太不容易了
Shure: Damn, this is tough.
Alice:基本就是靠油把这个蛋跟铁隔开了
Alice: Basically, the oil is just keeping the egg from touching the pan.
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure:  可以
Shure: Okay.
Shure:  牛逼的
Shure: Awesome.
Alice:你这个不煎好再下下一个吗
Alice: Are you not going to make another one if this one doesn't turn out well?
Shure:  不用煎下
Shure: No need to make another.
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Shure:  再补补钙
Shure: Let's add some calcium.
Shure:  完了这摊子太太大了
Shure: Man, this is such a mess.
Alice:没事
Alice: It's okay.
Shure:  OK那个可以了
Shure: Okay, that should do it.
Shure:  完了完了
Shure: Done, done.
Alice:拿筷子夹吧
Alice: Use chopsticks to pick it up.
Shure:  完美的煎蛋
Shure: Perfect fried egg.
Alice:这么多油还在粘锅
Alice: So much oil, and it's still sticking.
Alice:家里用的锅
Alice: The pan at home...
Alice:喷两下那个油壶就能煎出来
Alice: Just needs a couple of sprays from the oil can to make a perfect egg.
Alice:完美无缝的蛋
Alice: Perfect seamless egg.
Alice:忍一下算了
Alice: Just bear with it.
Shure:  我只能说不忍直视
Shure: I can't even look at it.
Alice:哈哈忍一下算了
Alice: Haha, just bear with it.
Alice:哦这是我的手机
Alice: Oh, this is my phone.
Alice:我说嘛
Alice: I knew it.
Alice:我什么时候有那么多的消息通知
Alice: When did I get so many notifications?
Alice:你那面包还煎不煎煎
Alice: Are you going to fry that bread?
Alice:雨轩你吃
Alice: Yuxuan, you eat.
Katrina:  我不用煎
Katrina: No need to fry.
Katrina:  我直接吃就行好
Katrina: I can just eat it as is.
Alice:好
Alice: Okay.
Shure:  塞两件衣服才就满了
Shure: Just two pieces of clothing and it's full.
Shure:  嘟嘟哎呦
Shure: Beep beep, oh no!
Shure:  你怎么还漏出来
Shure: How are you still leaking?
Shure:  本来挺好
Shure: It was fine before.
Shure:  我他妈恨不得弄死你
Shure: I'm so mad I could kill you.
Shure:  这样就我没有煎过这些碎的
Shure: I've never fried these broken pieces before.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure:  销毁一下证据
Shure: Let's destroy the evidence.
Alice:来
Alice: Here.
Alice:妈把这个拿走
Alice:过冷水
Alice: Rinse it with cold water.
Shure:  用过冷水吗
Shure: Did you use cold water?
Alice:啊
Alice: Huh?
Alice:不用过冷水
Alice: No need to use cold water.
Shure:  都行都行
Shure: Either way is fine.
Shure:  荷包蛋
Shure: Fried egg.
Alice:讲究啊
Alice: So particular.
Alice:用黄油煎
Alice: Fry it with butter.
Shure:  但是这黄油好难拆
Shure: But this butter is so hard to open.
Shure:  这黄油可不在这里
Shure: The butter isn't here.
Shure:  我想切就是切
Shure: I want to cut it, so I'll cut it.
Alice:啊
Alice: Huh?
Alice:直接就是这样切一块就行
Alice: Just cut a piece directly like this.
Shure:  就是这样
Shure: Just like this.
Shure:  来吧上刀
Shure: Come on, get the knife.
Shure:  刀不在这一搁
Shure: The knife isn't here.
Alice:刀在这呢
Alice: The knife is here.
Shure:  早上刷的
Shure: Cleaned it this morning.
Alice:那你直接用吧
Alice: Then just use it directly.
Alice:你搁这呗
Alice: Put it here.
Alice:不是烤那蛋糕的那个啥
Alice: Isn't that for baking the cake?
Alice:你把这个抠下来
Alice: Pull this off.
Alice:然后这个还能当盖盖上去
Alice: Then you can use this as a lid.
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Shure:  你说的对
Shure: You're right.
Katrina:  来两个草莓吧
Katrina: Let's have two strawberries.
Alice:看到了
Alice: I see it.
Alice:你这衣服是要洗的吗
Alice: Are you going to wash these clothes?
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes.
Alice:是的你没开
Alice: Yes, but you didn't start it.
Shure:  对对我等一会弄完了
Shure: Right, right, I'll do it in a bit.
Alice:我给你开了吧
Alice: Should I start it for you?
Shure:  啊行
Shure: Ah, okay.
Shure:  你帮我倒点洗衣液然后开了就行
Shure: Just pour some detergent and start it.
Alice:咋这么多虫子呀
Alice: Why are there so many bugs?
Alice:多少衣服呀
Alice: How many clothes are there?
Alice:加一点
Alice: Add a bit more.
Katrina:  那个电饭还能吃吗
Katrina: Is that rice cooker still edible?
Alice:能吧
Alice: Probably.
Alice:吃鸡蛋吗
Alice: Want some eggs?
Alice:微微
Alice: Tasha.
Alice:水煮蛋要吗
Alice: Do you want boiled eggs?
Alice:趁热吃吧
Alice: Eat while it's hot.
Alice:这是干嘛
Alice: What's this for?
Shure:  早起一杯黑咖啡
Shure: A cup of black coffee in the morning.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice:我涮一下
Shure:  面包片对
Shure: Toast, right.
Shure:  煎的面包片
Shure: Toasted bread.
Shure:  杨老板呢
Shure: Where's Jake?
Tasha: 鲜牛奶应该可以吧
Tasha: Fresh milk should be fine, right?
Lucia: 牛奶在那边
Lucia: The milk is over there.
Tasha: 在哪边那呢
Tasha: Where is it?
Alice:那呢看见了吗
Alice: Over there, did you see it?
Tasha: 哎另一个呢
Tasha: Hey, where's the other one?
Lucia: 你那个是用完了吗嗯
Lucia: Did you finish the other one?
Katrina:  昨天有买新的吗
Katrina: Did we buy a new one yesterday?
Tasha: 另一瓶喝完了吗
Tasha: Did you finish the other bottle?
Katrina:  本来就是
Katrina: It was like that to begin with.
Katrina:  上一次买两瓶
Katrina: Last time we bought two bottles.
Katrina:  一瓶已经喝完了
Katrina: One bottle is already finished.
Shure:  杨老板到尝尝面包吧
Shure: Jake, come and try the bread.
Shure:  杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Jake: 先对个齐
Jake: Let’s align it first.
Jake: 来
Jake: Come on.
Shure:  面包蘸番茄酱
Shure: Bread dipped in ketchup.
Tasha: 还有人要喝牛奶吗
Tasha: Does anyone want milk?
Tasha: 好吧没有
Tasha: Alright, no one wants.
Lucia: 我可以喝
Lucia: I can drink.
Tasha: 算了我看到了
Tasha: Forget it, I saw you.
Tasha: 你都已经背叛了
Tasha: You already betrayed.
Lucia: 等我把这这个橙汁不是柠檬汁喝完了
Lucia: Let me finish this orange juice, not lemonade.
Lucia: 就喝
Lucia: Then I'll drink it.
Tasha: 黄油少切一点啊
Tasha: Cut a bit less butter.
Tasha: 好没关系
Tasha: Alright, no worries.
Tasha: 你就切吧
Tasha: Just cut it.
Tasha: 这么多可以
Tasha: This much is fine.
Shure:  哈哈放冰箱里
Shure: Haha, put it in the fridge.
Jake: 我吃哪一个呢
Jake: Which one should I eat?
Shure:  你尝个面包吧
Shure: Try some bread.
Shure:  那面包嘎嘎香
Shure: That bread is super crispy.
Tasha: 黄油就奶香奶香的了已经
Tasha: The butter is already so creamy.
Shure:  是我碰到的吗
Shure: Did I bump into it?
Katrina:  不知道
Katrina: I don’t know.
Tasha: 看摄像头
Tasha: Check the camera.
Jake: 回头看摄像头
Jake: Check the camera later.
Shure:  不是这必须调一下VCR我
Shure: No, we must review the VCR.
Shure:  啊这窜下去了是吧
Shure: Ah, it slipped down, right?
Katrina:  把杯子放在这上
Katrina: Put the cup here.
Jake: 正位数值扫一扫
Jake: Scan the correct number.
Tasha: 天呐摔了几个
Tasha: Oh my, how many fell?
Shure:  不是他应该会掉到我的鞋里吧
Shure: No, it should have fallen into my shoe.
Tasha: 啊你抖一抖
Tasha: Ah, shake it off.
Shure:  嗯我抖一抖
Shure: Hmm, I'll shake it off.
Shure:  你把面包再给我
Shure: Give me the bread again.
Shure:  我再煎一片面包
Shure: I’ll fry another piece.
Katrina:  我们有扫帚吗
Katrina: Do we have a broom?
Tasha: 煎一片还是两片
Tasha: One slice or two slices?
Alice:有
Alice: Yes.
Tasha: 这么多黄油
Tasha: So much butter.
Tasha: 就煎一片
Tasha: Just for one slice.
Jake: 在哪来着
Jake: Where is it again?
Shure:  没有没有没有
Shure: No, no, no.
Tasha: 哦哦还有裹蛋糕液
Tasha: Oh, and coat it with cake batter.
Shure:  好吃吗这个还行吧
Shure: Is this tasty? It's okay, right?
Tasha: 好吃
Tasha: Delicious.
Lucia: 特别香
Lucia: Smells amazing.
Alice:哦对不起
Alice: Oh, sorry.
Jake: 都是凶器啊
Jake: These are all dangerous tools.
Shure:  是啊就告诉AI这都是危险物品
Shure: Yeah, just tell the AI these are all dangerous items.
Shure:  杨老板在新加坡自己给自己做吃的吗
Shure: Jake, do you cook for yourself in Singapore?
Jake: 不给开火
Jake: Can't use the stove.
Jake: 屋里不给开火
Jake: Can't use the stove indoors.
Shure:  从来没开过火是吗
Shure: Never used the stove, right?
Jake: 屋里不给开火
Jake: Can't use the stove indoors.
Jake: 就是就是
Jake: Exactly, exactly.
Jake: 没开过火
Jake: Never used the stove.
Jake: 确实没开过火
Jake: Really never used it.
Alice:抖抖吧你
Alice: Shake it a bit.
Alice:你不得往下抖吗
Alice: Don't you need to shake it down?
Alice:你前面又出不去
Alice: You can't get out from the front.
Alice:劝你穿个袜子
Alice: I suggest you wear socks.
Shure:  应该问题不大
Shure: Should be fine.
Shure:  没事
Shure: No worries.
Jake: 你要不去检查一下
Jake: Maybe you should go check it out.
Shure:  行我一会去厕所检查一下嗯
Shure: Okay, I'll go check it in the bathroom later.
Shure:  盘子端过来一下
Shure: Bring the plate over.
Shure:  把这个拿着
Shure: Hold this.
Lucia: 哎那个刚
Lucia: Hey, that just...
Lucia: 那盘子在哪
Lucia: Where's the plate?
Lucia: 用这煎蛋盘可以吗
Lucia: Can we use this egg pan?
Shure:  煎蛋也可以吃
Shure: You can eat the eggs too.
Shure:  但煎蛋没有没撒盐
Shure: But the eggs don't have any salt.
Lucia: 那就先用这盘盛一下吧
Lucia: Let's use this plate for now.
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Lucia: 嗯可以先放过去了是吧
Lucia: Hmm, can we place it over there now?
Tasha: AI拍了短片
Tasha: AI made a short film.
Jake: 哼OK
Jake: Hmm, OK.
Alice:Lucy啊你帮我把它倒在这里面吧
Alice: Lucy, can you pour it in here for me?
Jake: 有咖啡喝吗
Jake: Is there any coffee?
Jake: 他是不是已经送来了
Jake: Has it already been delivered?
Jake: 你看看那边有没有啊
Jake: Check over there, is there any?
Alice:还有
Alice: There's more.
Lucia: 再套个袋子
Lucia: Put another bag on it.
Lucia: 要不咱垃圾袋在哪
Lucia: Or where are our trash bags?
Alice:把这个再扫你
Alice: Sweep this up again.
Alice:嗯不会
Alice: Hmm, no.
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Ah!
Lucia: 撒出去了一样 再来一次
Lucia: 那我再洗个手
Lucia: I'll wash my hands again.
Jake: 打碎了3个杯子
Jake: Broke three cups.
Jake: 几个杯子
Jake: How many cups?
Alice:笔跟纸是不是不在这
Alice: Isn't the pen and paper here?
Jake: 什么纸
Jake: What paper?
Alice:便签跟
Alice: Sticky notes and...
Jake: 便签纸
Jake: Sticky notes.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Jake: 那后面也好你看看
Jake: Check the back as well.
Alice:好像没有吧
Alice: Doesn't seem like it.
Katrina:  没有我昨天放冰箱的呀
Katrina: No, I put it in the fridge yesterday.
Jake: 有吗
Jake: Is it there?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Shure:  真没不是
Shure: Really, it's not there.
Shure:  好奇怪丢了一袋面包
Shure: So weird, a bag of bread is missing.
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure:  难受
Shure: Feels bad.
Shure:  对咱昨天没吃
Shure: Yeah, we didn't eat it yesterday.
Shure:  而昨天生蚝忘吃了
Shure: And we forgot to eat the oysters yesterday.
Shure:  该补的忘补了
Shure: Forgot to replenish what we missed.
Shure:  现在感觉整个人身体被掏空
Shure: Now I feel totally drained.
Tasha: 今天来一个清蒸
Tasha: Let's have a steamed dish today.
Tasha: 清蒸生蚝
Tasha: Steamed oysters.
Tasha: 叫什么来着
Tasha: What was it called again?
Tasha: 蒜蒜蒜蓉生蚝
Tasha: Garlic steamed oysters.
Lucia: 哦蒜蓉粉丝那种
Lucia: Oh, like garlic and vermicelli ones?
Jake: 那再蒸点
Jake: Let's steam some more.
Jake: 再蒸三刀
Jake: Steam three more.
Tasha: 有那个蒸笼呀
Tasha: We have that steamer, right?
Tasha: 很好蒸的
Tasha: It's easy to steam.
Jake: 得有得有
Jake: Definitely, definitely.
Jake: 生蚝首先得有生蚝
Jake: You need oysters first.
Tasha: 不是有吗
Tasha: Don't we have them?
Lucia: 昨晚是没放冰箱
Lucia: They weren't put in the fridge last night.
Shure:  不到4新币
Shure: Less than 4 Singapore dollars.
Jake: 但是损失了100
Jake: But we lost 100.
Katrina:  我想尝一小片给谁
Katrina: I want to try a small piece, give it to someone.
Katrina:  就是我吃不完一整片
Katrina: I can't finish a whole piece.
Katrina:  那我直接撕了
Katrina: I'll just tear it off then.
Tasha: 啊真的
Tasha: Oh really.
Tasha: 19块9一袋
Tasha: 19.9 per bag.
Jake: 二楼也没有面包哈
Jake: There's no bread on the second floor either.
Shure:  对啊好奇怪啊
Shure: Yeah, that's so weird.
Shure:  就活生生就丢了
Shure: It just disappeared.
Alice:们结账的时候结一袋还是两袋
Alice: Did we check out with one bag or two bags?
Katrina:  两袋两袋
Katrina: Two bags, two bags.
Lucia: 两袋
Katrina:  购物车里的人
Katrina: The person in the shopping cart.
Tasha: 怎么会丢掉一袋面包
Tasha: How could we lose a bag of bread?
Katrina:  我记得
Katrina: I remember.
Lucia: 啊少了一袋吗
Lucia: Oh, one bag is missing?
Lucia: 我昨天放那个蛋清液的时候
Lucia: When I put the egg whites in yesterday.
Lucia: 还是两袋呢
Lucia: There were still two bags.
Tasha: 可是我记得昨天这个里面还有一袋啊
Tasha: But I remember there was one bag left in here yesterday.
Katrina:  对我就有两袋放冰箱了都
Katrina: Yeah, I put two bags in the fridge.
Shure:  到底是谁偷吃
Shure: Who ate it?
Tasha: 在这呢
Tasha: Here it is.
Katrina:  这不是吗这后面
Katrina: Isn't this it, behind here?
Shure:  原来你没偷吃啊
Shure: So you didn't sneak it, huh?
Shure:  对不起是我污蔑你了
Shure: Sorry, I falsely accused you.
Katrina:  我偷吃也不可能偷吃这个
Katrina: Even if I stole, I wouldn't steal this.
Katrina:  泡杯咖啡吧
Katrina: Let's make a cup of coffee.
Alice:今天周几啊周五吗
Alice: What day is it today, Friday?
Jake: 这哪来的
Jake: Where did this come from?
Shure:  就是在冰箱里
Shure: It was in the fridge.
Shure:  刚刚大家没找到
Shure: Everyone just missed it earlier.
Jake: 这么有意思
Jake: So interesting.
Shure:  藏在那个北冰洋后面呢
Shure: It was hidden behind the Arctic Ocean.
Shure:  从底下掏出蛋吃是吗
Shure: Taking out eggs from the bottom, right?
Katrina:  对哈哈哈
Katrina: Yeah hahaha
Shure:  完美收官
Shure: Perfect ending
Katrina:  呃
Katrina: Uh
Lucia: 棒棒
Lucia: Awesome
Jake: 你也和雨拍
Jake: You also film with rain
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm
Jake: 来插管
Jake: Let's insert the tube
Alice:我的线
Alice: My line
Jake: 你线在这
Jake: Your line is here
Jake: 不要着急限速
Jake: Don't rush, slow down
Alice:结束了吗
Alice: Is it over?
Jake: 要插管
Jake: Need to insert the tube
Jake: 是还没是要开始
Jake: It's not over, it’s about to start
Katrina:  他没显示电量
Katrina: It's not showing battery
Katrina:  是没电
Katrina: It's out of battery
Jake: 需要按一下
Jake: You need to press it
Jake: 请插管啊
Jake: Please insert the tube
Lucia: 谢谢稍等
Lucia: Thanks, wait a moment
Jake: 有多少个
Jake: How many are there?
Shure:  太不容易了
Shure: It's not easy
Shure:  我们又活过了一天
Shure: We survived another day
Shure:  就每天感觉把自己又养活一天
Shure: Feels like we manage to live one more day every day
Shure:  非常有成就感
Shure: It's very fulfilling
Jake: 那个有那个生命条是吧
Jake: There's that life bar, right?
Shure:  什么生命条
Shure: What life bar?
Jake: 就是每个人头上一个生命条
Jake: Like, everyone has a life bar above their head
Jake: 刚起床的时候大概到到个20吧
Jake: When you just wake up, it's probably around 20
Jake: 哦吃完了之后到几啊
Jake: Oh, after you eat, how much does it go up?
Lucia: 吃一口
Lucia: Take a bite
Jake: 都是赛博人
Jake: We're all cyborgs
Jake: 吃了一口然后生命条就能加个5
Jake: Take a bite and the life bar goes up by 5
Katrina:  差不多
Katrina: Pretty much
Lucia: 哦噢我自己咬着
Lucia: Oh, I bit myself
Katrina:  生命之减减
Katrina: Life points deducted
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Shure:  看着没没肉不行是吧
Shure: You can't do without meat, right?
Shure:  要咬自己的
Shure: You have to bite yourself
Jake: 准备插管
Jake: Get ready to insert the tube
Jake: 给你拿充电宝
Jake: I'll get you a power bank
Lucia: 主要是您您做的这面包太好吃了
Lucia: Mainly because the bread you made is so delicious
Katrina:  是怎么做
Katrina: How do you do it?
Katrina:  就是嗯把嗯然后呢
Katrina: You just, uh, put, um, and then...
Shure:  然后裹上
Shure: Then coat it.
Shure:  徐志瑶也太厉害了
Shure: Xu Zhiyao is amazing.
Shure:  然后最好拿黄油煎
Shure: Then it's best to fry it with butter.
Shure:  就是切下来一片然后放入锅
Shure: Just cut off a piece and put it in the pan.
Shure:  然后就可以化掉
Shure: Then it can melt.
Shure:  然后再把等它化掉之后
Shure: After it melts...
Shure:  然后你把那个面包放进去
Shure: Then you put the bread in.
Jake: 歇着
Jake: Take a rest.
Shure:  动手吧
Shure: Get to work.
Lucia: 我的血量就会在这一直递减
Lucia: My health keeps dropping.
Lucia: 就是持续性的效应
Lucia: It's a continuous effect.
Jake: 得一直补
Jake: You have to keep replenishing.
Jake: 得插管
Jake: Need to insert a tube.
Lucia: 在一直喝那个魔法药水
Lucia: Keep drinking that magic potion.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Shure:  什么魔法药水哦
Shure: What magic potion?
Jake: 她掉血了啊
Jake: She's losing health!
Lucia: 好疼啊哈哈哈
Lucia: It hurts so much, hahaha.
Jake: 这叫中毒
Jake: That's called being poisoned.
Jake: 中毒效应
Jake: Poison effect.
Tasha: 可见你对这个鸡蛋咬的有多重
Tasha: Shows how hard you bit that egg.
Lucia: 不是都好久没咬到自己舌头了
Lucia: I haven't bitten my tongue in so long.
Jake: 你把外头收拾收拾
Jake: Clean up outside.
Jake: 今天天适合出去玩
Jake: Today’s perfect for going out.
Shure:  我的咖啡
Shure: My coffee...
Katrina:  啊啊你这个水杯好可爱啊
Katrina: Ah, your water bottle is so cute!
Alice:我的吗这是我其中一个水杯
Alice: Mine? This is just one of my water bottles.
Alice:你没见过另一个我
Alice: You haven't seen my other one.
Alice:另一个上面全是
Alice: The other one is covered with...
Alice:贴花还是3D立体的
Alice: Stickers, or it's 3D.
Alice:这是我最简朴的水杯了
Alice: This is my simplest water bottle.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice:一个花里胡哨的
Alice: One is really fancy.
Lucia: 奢华有内涵
Lucia: You speak so eloquently.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Alice:哎我说咋这么吵呢
Alice: Hey, why is it so noisy?
Alice:怎么不关这个呢
Alice: Why not turn it off?
Alice:脑壳嗡嗡
Alice: My head is buzzing.
Lucia: 让我看看我的京东
Lucia: Let me check my JD app.
Alice:哦没事
Alice: Oh, it's fine.
Alice:吓死我了
Alice: You scared me!
Alice:我们今天什么时候压花嘞
Alice: When are we pressing flowers today?
Katrina:  嗯随便都行
Katrina: Hmm, anytime is fine.
Alice:感觉康乃馨比较坚挺
Alice: I feel like carnations are pretty sturdy.
Alice:花期比较长
Alice: They last quite long.
Lucia: 好这应该是我的
Lucia: Okay, this should be mine.
Lucia: 就想开了一个
Lucia: Just one has bloomed.
Lucia: 其他的吧
Lucia: The others...
Lucia: 陆陆续续的想开
Lucia: Are starting to bloom gradually.
Alice:有点蔫开始有点蔫吧了
Alice: Some are wilting a bit, right?
Alice:没那么硬了
Alice: Not as firm anymore.
Katrina:  你你那个
Katrina: You, you, um...
Katrina:  你那个水牡丹
Katrina: Your water peony...
Katrina:  是不是也是要我们每个人的参与
Katrina: Does it need everyone's participation?
Lucia: 最好是我买的是那个串珠
Lucia: Ideally, yes. I bought some beads.
Lucia: 和那个叫什么欧根纱
Lucia: And something called organza.
Lucia: 然后6个人用他肯定够用
Lucia: Six people can definitely use them.
Lucia: 嗯但是现在就是
Lucia: Hmm, but right now...
Lucia: 因为我觉得材料包那个
Lucia: I think the material pack...
Lucia: 就是我之前做过
Lucia: That I used before...
Lucia: 我觉得没有我刷到的那个教程好看
Lucia: Doesn't look as good as the tutorial I saw.
Lucia: 然后而且就是用就是废
Lucia: And using waste bottles is more eco-friendly.
Lucia: 废瓶子做就更符合我们的环保理念
Lucia: But I don't know if we have six bottles.
Lucia: 但我现在不知道有没有6个瓶子
Lucia: Can we use bottles?
Lucia: 可以让我们做瓶子吗
Lucia: To make the bottles?
Katrina:  嗯就那种因为要稍微的大一点
Katrina: Yeah, but they need to be a bit larger.
Lucia: 其实像这个瓶子就还可以我觉得
Lucia: Actually, this bottle seems good enough, I think.
Lucia: 嗯这个对
Lucia: Hmm, this one, yeah.
Lucia: 但是这个瓶子的话就太小了
Lucia: But this bottle is a bit too small.
Lucia: 那天果粒橙那瓶还在吗
Lucia: Is that bottle of Minute Maid still here?
Alice:果粒橙应该
Tasha: 扔掉了
Alice:应该从这里毕业了
Alice: It should have graduated from here.
Lucia: 因为果粒橙那个他外面这个壳不光滑所以
Lucia: Because the Minute Maid bottle has a rough exterior, so...
Alice:露西亚你要鸡蛋吗
Alice: Lucia, do you want some eggs?
Alice:煮的
Alice: Boiled ones.
Lucia: 煮鸡蛋吗
Lucia: Boiled eggs?
Lucia: 嗯好
Lucia: Hmm, sure.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Lucia: 那我也来一个好了
Lucia: Then I'll have one too.
Lucia: 其实我刚刚吃了一个煎蛋
Lucia: Actually, I just had a fried egg.
Alice:没关系
Alice: It's okay.
Tasha: 今天是全蛋宴是吗
Tasha: Is today an all-egg feast?
Tasha: 煮蛋蒸蛋煎蛋
Tasha: Boiled eggs, steamed eggs, fried eggs.
Shure:  不能不能辜负了护蛋使者的护蛋行动
Shure: We can't let the Egg Protector's efforts go to waste.
Alice:护蛋使者
Alice: Egg Protector?
Tasha: 孵蛋使者
Tasha: The Egg Incubator.
Alice: 护蛋使者
Alice: Egg Protector.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Lucia: 现在就看那个串珠和欧根纱
Lucia: Now we just wait for the beads and organza.
Lucia: 什么时候能到
Lucia: When will they arrive?
Alice:早上水煮鸡蛋
Alice: Boiled eggs in the morning.
Alice:中午蒸鸡蛋晚上鸡蛋的妈
Alice: Steamed eggs for lunch, and eggs for dinner.
Lucia: 哎有人吃鸡吗
Lucia: Hey, anyone eating chicken?
Alice:和平精英吗
Alice: You mean in PUBG?
Alice:不哦对对对很菜
Alice: Oh, right, right, not really good at it.
Lucia: 其实我也好久没玩那个了
Lucia: Actually, I haven't played it in a while.
Tasha: 下棋下棋
Tasha: Chess, chess.
Tasha: 打麻将的呢
Tasha: How about mahjong?
Shure:  打麻将估计费点劲
Shure: Mahjong might be a bit tricky.
Lucia: 但我今天发现
Lucia: But today I found out...
Lucia: 我的收藏夹里的游戏今天打五折
Lucia: The games in my favorites are 50% off today.
Lucia: 我要不要登录一下
Lucia: Should I log in?
Lucia: 先把它拿下来
Lucia: And buy them now?
Alice:Steam吗
Alice: On Steam?
Alice:你玩啥呀
Alice: What are you playing?
Tasha: 来不就行了吗
Tasha: Is it fun?
Lucia: 最近在玩使命召唤
Lucia: Recently, I've been playing Call of Duty.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Shure:  有点有点痴心妄想的我感觉
Shure: I feel like it's a bit of wishful thinking.
Alice:那个麻将桌是本来就在那的吗
Alice: Was that mahjong table always there?
Tasha: 很明显
Tasha: Obviously not.
Tasha: 是被他私藏进来的
Tasha: He must have secretly brought it in.
Alice:私藏进来的
Alice: Secretly brought it in?
Shure:  主要他
Shure: Mainly because he...
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Shure:  哎那就这样吧
Shure: Well, let's leave it at that.
Lucia: 我觉得我的这个芍药还能再泡两天
Lucia: I think my peonies can last another two days.
Katrina:  但压花需要两三天啊
Katrina: But pressed flowers need two to three days.
Lucia: 但是他现在还没有开
Lucia: But it hasn't bloomed yet.
Katrina:  没有一朵芍药
Katrina: Not a single peony.
Alice:那你用康乃馨吧
Alice: Then use carnations.
Alice:你的康乃馨开的好盛大
Alice: Your carnations are blooming so beautifully.
Lucia: 对我康乃馨好旺
Lucia: Yeah, my carnations are thriving.
Lucia: 但是芍药好自闭
Lucia: But the peonies are so shy.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Alice:我的我的勺眼已经开始卸
Alice: Mine have already started to shed.
Lucia: 他还没想开
Lucia: They haven't opened yet.
Jake: 他能催熟吗
Jake: Can they be forced to ripen?
Jake: 一天速成速开
Jake: Speed them up in one day.
Alice:催熟
Lucia: 你以为这是期末考试啊
Lucia: Do you think this is a final exam?
Jake: 哈哈哈想让来他就开
Jake: Hahaha, just open whenever you want.
Alice:我想开了
Alice: I feel like opening up.
Lucia: 想开到一半就自闭了
Lucia: Wanted to open halfway but got shy.
Alice:我自闭了
Alice: I feel shy.
Katrina:  为啥呀熬夜可难受了
Katrina: Why? Staying up late is so painful.
Shure:  然后把那个什么弄完
Shure: Then finish that thing.
Shure:  这样就没有顾虑了
Shure: Then you won't have to worry.
Jake: 把那什么那什么呀
Jake: Finish what?
Shure:  把我的毕设
Shure: My thesis.
Shure:  我的毕设报告
Shure: My thesis report.
Shure:  就剩最后那么一neinei
Shure: There's just one last little bit left.
Jake: 好那你直播做毕设
Jake: Okay, then live stream your thesis work.
Jake: 是压出来了吗
Jake: Is it pressed out?
Katrina:  哈哈哈怎么压的来
Katrina: Hahaha, how did you press it?
Katrina:  变干瘪了
Katrina: It turned out flat.
Shure:  它压出了不一样的风格
Shure: It got pressed into a different style.
Jake: 烟花嗯
Jake: Fireworks, hmm.
Alice:先去上个厕所
Alice: Let me go to the bathroom first.
Alice:哎
Alice: Oh.
Jake: 网上长啥样
Jake: How does it look online?
Katrina:  难道是要把它那个花瓣一个个剥下来
Katrina: Do you have to peel off each petal?
Katrina:  然后那样子压吗
Katrina: And then press it like that?
Katrina:  然后如果整个压花的话
Katrina: If you press the whole flower,
Katrina:  它居然是这个样子
Katrina: It turns out like this.
Katrina:  我给你看当初的那一张图
Katrina: Let me show you the picture from before.
Jake: 花瓣大
Jake: The petals are big.
Katrina:  对就是直接这样子压的话
Katrina: Yeah, if you press it directly like this,
Katrina:  你看他会变成这样
Katrina: You see, it turns out like this.
Katrina:  要么就把它拆开
Katrina: Or just take it apart.
Lucia: 我让我查查有没有什么攻略
Lucia: Let me check if there are any guides.
Katrina:  搜一下压花攻略
Katrina: Search for pressed flower guides.
Jake: 可以研究研究
Jake: We can look into it.
Jake: 你看啥呢
Jake: What are you looking at?
Tasha: 呵呵
Tasha: Haha.
Jake: 好笑
Jake: Funny.
Jake: 嗯好
Jake: Hmm, okay.
Tasha: 好无聊呀
Tasha: So boring.
Tasha: 下棋吗
Tasha: Want to play chess?
Tasha: 找不到事干
Tasha: Can't find anything to do.
Shure:  老板他要摸鱼
Shure: The boss wants to slack off.
Jake: 收拾收拾跳跳舞
Jake: Clean up and dance.
Jake: 今天也没啥事
Jake: Nothing much to do today.
Jake: 收拾收拾房间好拆点快递
Jake: Clean up the room, maybe open some packages.
Jake: 快递还没到
Jake: Packages aren't here yet.
Lucia: 开始装修房子
Lucia: Start renovating the house.
Jake: 对快递还没到呢
Jake: Yeah, the packages aren't here yet.
Tasha: 工具还没到呢没办法装修
Tasha: Tools haven't arrived, can't renovate.
Lucia: 到了一个
Lucia: One has arrived.
Jake: 那就等那我问问快递什么时候到
Jake: Then let's wait. I'll ask when the rest will arrive.
Jake: 呃或者再开个小车过去
Jake: Uh, or we can take a small car over.
Lucia: 对我今天应该还有一个快递可以到
Lucia: Yeah, I should have another package arriving today.
Lucia: 京东还是快
Lucia: JD is pretty fast.
Lucia: 淘宝上那些
Lucia: Those on Taobao...
Lucia: 我就希望他明天能到
Lucia: I just hope they arrive by tomorrow.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 那个
Jake: Well...
Jake: 那要不集体玩狗去也行
Jake: How about we all go play with the dog together?
Shure:  集体玩狗
Shure: Play with the dog together?
Shure:  玩狗 6个人一起撸狗是吧
Shure: All six of us petting the dog?
Lucia: 狗都薅秃了
Lucia: The dog will go bald.
Jake: 狗在哪啊
Jake: Where's the dog?
Lucia: 狗在哪
Lucia: Where's the dog?
Jake: 要走多久啊
Jake: How far is it?
Shure:  200米吧
Shure: About 200 meters.
Jake: 那可以那可以去玩狗去
Jake: Okay, then let's go play with the dog.
Shure:  狗就说你们才是真的狗
Shure: The dog might think you guys are the real dogs.
Lucia: 哈哈哈我可能不是人
Lucia: Hahaha, I might not be human.
Lucia: 但你们是真的狗
Lucia: But you guys are the real dogs.
Shure:  你说你说
Shure: Go ahead, tell me.
Shure:  这句话怎么给南阳理工同学翻译呢
Shure: How do you translate this sentence for the students at Nanyang Technological University?
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Lucia: 没事新加坡中文普及率应该很高
Lucia: No worries, the Chinese literacy rate in Singapore should be quite high.
Lucia: 官方语言之一
Lucia: It's one of the official languages.
Shure:  班dog dog哈哈哈
Shure: Ban dog dog hahaha
Jake: Doggy Doggy dogger
Jake: 就是他们也有那种表情包嘛
Jake: They also have those kinds of memes, right?
Jake: 啊Doggy
Jake: Ah, Doggy
Lucia: 嗯哇这是好多年前的表情包了
Lucia: Hmm, wow, that's such an old meme.
Shure:  咱们这个就这么放着
Shure: Let's just leave this here.
Shure:  谁干的耶
Shure: Who did this, hey?
Lucia: 我昨天忘洗了吗
Lucia: Did I forget to wash it yesterday?
Shure:  谁干的
Shure: Who did this?
Jake: 来我们一人洗一个
Jake: Come on, let's each wash one.
Lucia: 啊谢谢你
Lucia: Oh, thank you.
Jake: 一人洗一个
Jake: Let's each wash one.
Shure:  我的我的衣服好了
Shure: My clothes are ready.
Lucia: 你啥意思
Lucia: What do you mean?
Jake: 你的衣服做好了
Jake: Your clothes are ready.
Lucia: 好谢谢
Lucia: Okay, thanks.
Shure:  我今天早上那个外面的谁的衣服掉了
Shure: This morning, whose clothes fell outside?
Lucia: 这要不要泡一会再洗之类的
Lucia: Should we soak this for a while before washing?
Lucia: 但这里面有有油
Lucia: But there's oil on it.
Lucia: 给他泡到
Lucia: Soak it in...
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh...
Lucia: 泡到这碗
Lucia: Soak it in this bowl.
Lucia: 这碗还是没
Lucia: This bowl is still...
Lucia: 没啥给他接点水
Lucia: There's nothing in it, just add some water.
Lucia: 然后等过一会再洗
Lucia: Then wait a bit before washing it.
Lucia: 要不然太难搓了
Lucia: Otherwise, it's too hard to scrub.
Jake: 好嘞啊
Jake: Got it.
Lucia: 啊这还打王者吗
Lucia: Oh, are we still playing King's Glory?
Lucia: 抱歉
Lucia: Sorry.
Lucia: 我昨天晚上的邪恶计划没实施了
Lucia: I didn't carry out my evil plan last night.
Lucia: 后来忘记了
Lucia: I forgot about it.
Lucia: 哈哈大反派忘记了他的邪恶计划哈哈
Lucia: Haha, the big villain forgot his evil plan, haha.
Jake: 变成了一个好人
Jake: Turned into a good person.
Jake: 为社会做起了贡献
Jake: Started contributing to society.
Lucia: 这什么神偷奶爸剧情
Lucia: What is this, a Despicable Me plot?
Lucia: 啊不
Lucia: Ah no
Lucia: 他其实最后没有变成好人
Lucia: He didn't actually turn into a good person in the end.
Jake: 只是莫名其妙的做了一些
Jake: He just inexplicably did some things.
Lucia: 对莫名其妙的做了一些好事
Lucia: Yeah, inexplicably did some good deeds.
Lucia: 这狗好像河马
Lucia: This dog looks like a hippo.
Lucia: 但它有可能不是狗
Lucia: But it might not be a dog.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 这河马腰挺细
Jake: This hippo has a pretty slim waist.
Lucia: 哈哈哈这不是为了要方便坐吗
Lucia: Hahaha, isn't that for easier sitting?
Lucia: 毕竟还是凳子
Lucia: After all, it's still a stool.
Jake: 两个人这样
Jake: Two people like this.
Jake: 黑棋
Jake: Black pieces.
Lucia: AI学习一下
Lucia: The AI learns.
Lucia: 就人类在房子里面
Lucia: When people are in the house.
Lucia: 就会干一些奇奇怪怪的事情
Lucia: They tend to do strange things.
Lucia: 让我想想我们的
Lucia: Let me think about our...
Lucia: 我们现在的瓶子不会就剩这俩了吧
Lucia: We don't just have these two bottles left, right?
Lucia: 这个是方的
Lucia: This one is square.
Lucia: 不太好用
Lucia: Not very useful.
Lucia: 只有那个稍微好用点
Lucia: Only that one is slightly useful.
Jake: 我们那个金币是谁买的呀
Jake: Who bought those gold coins of ours?
Jake: 就是拍卖用的金币
Jake: The gold coins for the auction.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 爆金币爆金币
Jake: Exploding gold coins, exploding gold coins.
Lucia: 哎我记得那天是谁说用贴对
Lucia: Hey, I remember someone said we could use stickers.
Lucia: 贴画就可以来着
Lucia: Stickers would work.
Lucia: 对所以应该是本来就有吧
Lucia: So it should be something we already had.
Lucia: 好像是雨轩
Lucia: I think it was Yu Xuan.
Lucia: 问问雨轩好
Lucia: Let's ask Yu Xuan.
Shure:  行不行咱们踩点纸壳子就行
Shure: If it doesn't work, we can step on cardboard.
Lucia: 可以有人要做狗吗
Lucia: Can someone be the dog?
Lucia: 不是有人
Lucia: Not someone.
Jake: 可以可以
Jake: Sure, sure.
Jake: 我们都很狗
Jake: We're all dogs.
Lucia: 有人做狗吗
Lucia: Anyone want to be the dog?
Shure:  狗弄完之后
Shure: After the dog is done.
Jake: 然后我们承认我们很
Jake: Then we admit we're very...
Jake: 我们可以做狗
Jake: We can be dogs.
Lucia: 就这个狗吧
Lucia: Just this dog then.
Lucia: 他可以他就是他
Lucia: 可以做的好一些
Lucia: 可以做的那个潦草一些
Jake: 那做狗吧
Jake: 今天我们一起做狗
Lucia: 今天我们一起做狗
Jake: 我们今天先玩狗
Lucia: 不是跟狗杠上了是吧
Lucia: 一会要撸狗是吧
Jake: 先先玩狗
Shure:  我们给他做一套铠甲
Lucia: 哈哈哈那这就交给您了
Lucia: 我这个难度有点高
Lucia: 对我觉得我们这纸箱还是挺多的
Lucia: 需要有
Shure:  我们中午吃什么呢
Lucia: 尺子
Jake: 中午还能吃什么呢
Jake: 我们有别的选项吗
Shure:  外卖是吗
Shure: Delivery, right?
Lucia: 整挺好
Lucia: Looks great.
Shure:  我们可以把或者或者或者鸡蛋全给炒
Shure: We could just fry all the eggs, or whatever.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure:  弄个柿子炒鸡蛋
Shure: Let's make scrambled eggs with tomatoes.
Shure:  再加个苜蓿是
Shure: And maybe add some alfalfa.
Lucia: 我得上去拿一个小白的帽去
Lucia: I need to go grab a hat from Little White.
Jake: 你听到了吧
Jake: Did you hear that?
Lucia: 不是啊什么呀
Lucia: No, what?
Lucia: 啊刚刚他说什么
Lucia: What did he just say?
Jake: 先做一个西红柿炒鸡蛋
Jake: First, make scrambled eggs with tomatoes.
Jake: 再做个木须肉
Jake: Then, make Moo Shu Pork.
Lucia: 哇别吧
Lucia: Wow, no way.
Lucia: 从我到哪里都请大家吃一大盘炒鸡蛋
Lucia: Everywhere I go, I treat everyone to a big plate of scrambled eggs.
Jake: 啊我觉得可以啊
Jake: I think that’s fine.
Jake: 最后一天我们就这么做吧
Jake: Let’s do that on the last day.
Lucia: 啊那我只负责炒西红柿炒鸡蛋
Lucia: I’ll only be in charge of scrambled eggs with tomatoes.
Lucia: 木须肉我不会做
Lucia: I can’t make Moo Shu Pork.
Jake: 那行那我
Jake: Alright then...
Jake: 那你会做木须肉吗
Jake: Can you make Moo Shu Pork?
Jake: 我那道理做做就能做
Jake: I think if I follow the recipe, I can make it.
Jake: 整点黄瓜
Jake: Get some cucumbers.
Jake: 买点黄瓜去
Jake: Let's go buy some cucumbers.
Lucia: 到时候给大家吃了
Lucia: We'll let everyone eat them later.
Lucia: 一个月都不想看见鸡蛋哈哈
Lucia: I don't want to see eggs for a whole month, haha.
Jake: 点个
Jake: Order a...
Jake: 要不就点外卖
Jake: Or let's just order takeout.
Jake: 西红柿炒蛋和木须肉
Jake: Tomato and egg stir-fry and moo shu pork.
Jake: 哈哈哈咱不做了
Jake: Hahaha, let's not cook anymore.
Jake: 你不是做毕设吗
Jake: Aren't you working on your thesis?
Shure:  对我要做毕设
Shure: Yeah, I need to work on my thesis.
Jake: 哈哈你这毕设
Jake: Haha, your thesis...
Lucia: 哎呀让我拿过来
Lucia: Oh, let me bring it over.
Jake: 挺美观的
Jake: It's quite nice.
Shure:  毕设哎
Shure: Thesis, huh.
Alice:的
Alice: Yeah.
Shure:  我要把我偷来的代码改成自己的
Shure: I need to change the code I stole to make it look like mine.
Shure:  呵呵呵这个杨老板应该很擅长吧
Shure: Haha, Jake, you're probably good at this, right?
Jake: 这个现在已经不偷代码了
Jake: I don't steal code anymore.
Shure:  现在都告原创了
Shure: Now it's all about originality.
Jake: GPT直接写了啊还还
Jake: GPT writes it directly now, still...
Alice:人呢
Alice: Where is everyone?